Peter Jackson says this is the last
Hobbit do you think there's any chance
there'll be another any chance because
people know much to be honest the truth
is there won't be because because jr.
Tolkien has the rights they said the
estate sold the rights for both The
Hobbit and and Lord of the Rings but
nothing else but I did I was doing press
with them Evangeline Lilly and Lee pace
recently Hugh both play elves and we
thought we might do an elven spin-off
you don't do it often spec we could do
an elven spin-off ourselves you know get
some get some iPhones and some GoPros
and the elves annihilate middle-earth
you know the elves annihilate Miller the
tantric sex style it's an anime intetics
I would have it of elven love and give
us violence
you heard it here first for Linda saying
there will be a tantric sex go pro porno
version of The Hobbit fantastic thicken
my budget movies that make a lots of
money I'd love to make a little cameo
you'd be great is enough you kidding me
could you imagine him with a long blonde
wig
[Applause]
he is shown helping me I'm about as on
Elvan as they come I am like I'm very
you saw that he is he middle the golfing
Red Nosed Reindeer there's an elf Herbie
the dentist and I just selling like that
kid he's a little puppet but my whole
life people said you're
you